the department has charged ilya
lichtenstein and heather morgan for
their alleged roles in a conspiracy to
launder stolen cryptocurrency taken
during the 2016 hack of a virtual
currency exchange as part of this
investigation the department of justice
has seized over 3.6 billion dollars
worth of that stolen cryptocurrency
this is the largest seizure of
cryptocurrency ever by u.s law
enforcement so so this story is insane
for many reasons yeah a new york city
couple who i'm calling bit bonnie and
crypto clyde
morgan calls herself the infamous
crocodile of wall street i'm many things
a rapper an economist a journalist a
writer
this woman it turns out has been
spitting wet fire everywhere that she's
been given a chance hodo
what i gotta do yodo our mission is
noble it would probably be best if we
started from the beginning
in august of 2016 a cryptocurrency
exchange called bitfinex was hacked and
at the time it was second largest
bitcoin hack of all time and wiping out
about 100 000 bitcoins
as time has gone on though and price of
bitcoin has risen that has grown
substantially so for years law
enforcement has been working quietly to
figure out who was responsible for the
hack and where was the money going and
as it turns out this couple had been
allegedly laundering the proceeds of
this
hack
before they met they were
independently trying to build careers
as
tech luminaries and investors and
entrepreneurs elia lichtenstein he
actually launched his own startup in
2011 with help from y combinator
and received funding from mark cuban it
received funding from 500 startups he
actually had not a bad start to his
career she had started her own company
salesfolk and
you know by all accounts we could see
that she was
traveling around the world and and you
know giving speeches and she also became
a contributor to forbes and inc
so the earliest interactions we could
find between ilia lichtenstein and
heather morgan were about a decade ago
when we found a testimonial that
ilya had actually left on
a company website that was run by
heather morgan
ilia kept a low profile on social media
for a long period of time
you know he almost posted nothing on
twitter and you know it was pretty tough
to find much social media presence for
him heather morgan on the other hand she
was prolific hi heather from salesfolk
here rip boys on payroll cause i'm so
damn wealthy you don't even know me
started company at 23 got no clue what
i'm about
what we could glean especially from
their social media presence primarily
heather morgan's was that they did a lot
of traveling
but in between all of their jet setting
they were actually based in new york and
it was in new york that they were trying
to set themselves up as tech luminaries
there were
minor players but at one point ilya was
able to invest in in a startup you know
as an angel investor alongside other
really prominent investors like mark
benioff the fact that we were able to
understand you know who she was from her
social media presence made the story of
of who she was uh much more fascinating
you know considering the size of the
alleged crime that has occurred here
when we spoke to people that knew the
couple they each
responded with shock when we spoke to
heather morgan's former professor at uc
davis he described a student who was
very impressive diligent had a very big
world view sought out opportunities to
travel around the globe when he learned
that she had potentially been involved
in this crime the underlying feeling he
was shocked the same was true of another
company executive that had actually
interviewed heather when she had been
building her profile as a business
leader that executive had also said that
it was really hard to believe that that
she was in the situation that she finds
herself in now the couple will be
appearing today february 11th uh in
court again and really remains unclear
what the future holds for them but
there's also a lot of questions still to
be answered it is significant that in
the justice department's uh indictment
they have not mentioned that morgan or
liechtenstein were responsible for the
hack that occurred only that they
controlled digital wallets that had
received proceeds of the hack so
there's still a huge questions to be
answered and
we're going to continue to
try and answer them
[Music]
you